RESPONSE THE COVERED NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE BORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES HAVE ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
IN THE CAPITAL WITH NONE OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. AND ROUTE FORTY TWO
OH THREE WITH ME OUR SANDERS
CORTESE DOLLY GLAZER MCGUIRE
BUT CHOI BOGUE AND PAM. TO
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT TO PARTICIPATE
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE THREE
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN
ZERO FIVE SIX NINE ZERO NINE.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
PRESAS LINE ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER
THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT.
POINTS RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE FOR
WATCHING HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE-HEAR FROM YOU WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
THE DECORUM DURING THE ALLEGED
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WELL EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS.
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS HARD
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL IMPATIENT
SO THAT ALL INTERESTED PARTIES
CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE SEVEN
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA THREE
BILLS ARE ON CONSENT THE BILL
SIGNED CONSENT R. I. NUMBER ONE
S. J. R. FOR. ITEM NUMBER TWO
AB TWENTY SEVEN. ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB THREE NINETY SIX.
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATION OF
BILLS BUT THE STAFF WAS A
QUORUM AND CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR LEYVA
HERE IF IT HERE- CHAU ABOVE.
THE TROUBLE CARE COURTESY DELI.
DELI HERE GLAZER. GLAZER HERE
MCGUIRE POUNDS. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO TAKE UP
THE CONSENT CALENDAR AT THIS
TIME MA'AM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CONSENT SENATOR LEYVA
HI. I- CHAU ABODE. A TROUBLED A
COURTESY DELI. DELI I GLAZER.
GLAZER. AYE MCGUIRE PAM. GOOD
WILL LEAVE THAT FROM WHO ARE AT
OF ALL RIGHT MEMBERS LET'S HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY ON AB FOUR
SEVENTEEN. PRESENT WHEN YOU ARE
READY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AT
AS WE KNOW OUR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SERVE OVER
TWO MILLION CALIFORNIANS
HELPING OF. A WIDE VARIETY OF
STUDENTS. TRANSFERRED TO UC'S
R. C. ISSUES GET THEIR BASIC
SKILLS- SOMETIMES LEARN ENGLISH
SECOND THOUGHT THAT BUT ALSO
HELP A RISING NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE. GETTING OUT
OF THE G. JUSTICE SYSTEM TRYING
TO GET THEIR LIVES BACK IN
ORDER THIS BILL WOULD SIMPLY
ESTABLISH A RISING SCHOLARS
NETWORK TO HELP THESE JUSTICE
ENROLLED STUDENTS AND THIS OF
COURSE WAS IS TWO FOLD- HELP
THESE INDIVIDUALS GET THEIR
LIVES BACK GOING AFTER
INCARCERATION. AND ALSO- MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE NOT A
STATISTIC AS FAR AS RECIDIVISM
SO IT CERTAINLY HELPS
CALIFORNIA'S WELL EVERY EVERY
INSTITUTION PRISON INSTITUTION
HAS A LONG WAIT LIST OF
INDIVIDUALS TRYING TO GET
HIGHER EDUCATION. THERE IS A
HUNGER AND A NEED FOR THIS AND
THIS WILL DOVETAIL WITH- BUDGET
ALLOCATION THAT WE'RE WAITING
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S SIGNATURE
AND EXPAND HIGHER EDUCATION FOR
JUSTICE INVOLVED STUDENTS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT LAST YEAR AT
THE THANK YOU. VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO LEAD SUPPORT NOW IT LOOKS
LIKE I HAVE TWO PEOPLE ON THE
LINE TAMI DELUNA AND REBECCA
SILBERT. ARE YOU EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES LET'S START WITH TAMI
DILEMMA PLEASE PROCEED. CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE SURE CAN. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME BUDGET HELLO MY
NAME'S TOM DILLARD I'M FORMERLY
INCARCERATED WHILE INCARCERATED
I TOOK PART IN THE HIGHER
EDUCATION- OPPORTUNITIES THEY
HAD THEIR- THEY WORK NECESSARY
STREAMLINED AND THERE REALLY
WASN'T A LOT OF ORGANIZATIONS
SO EACH TIME I WAS TRANSFERRED
TO A DIFFERENT INSTITUTION. AND
BASICALLY KIND OF START OVER
AND APPLYING FOR SCHOOL AND
ALSO- GOING TO DIFFERENT
SCHOOLS AT THE SAME TIME SO. I
EARNED A LOT OF CREDIT EARNED
TWO DEGREES INSIDE BUT NEITHER
OF WHICH I REALLY- HAD ANY YOU
KNOW IDEA WHAT I WAS GOING TO
DO WITH THOSE DEGREES. SO WHEN
I CAME OUT- TWO YEARS AGO I
WENT TO SAC CITY AND I STARTED-
ASKING AROUND ABOUT THAT WE
EMERGENCY CALLERS PROGRAM
WHICH- CATERED TO FORMING CAR
STRAIGHT INDIVIDUALS SUCH AS
MYSELF. I WAS STILL IN THE
OFFICE I WAS GIVEN LIKE A
MENTOR AND BEFORE I KNOW WHAT I
WAS SIGNED UP FOR CLASSES THAT
I WAS GIVEN A LITTLE BIT OF
MORE- BANTERING AS FAR AS LIKE
WHAT I SHOULD FOCUS ON WHAT I
WOULD YOU KNOW LIKE DO WHAT YOU
KNOW INTERESTED ME IN. HIM
BEFORE I KNOW IT I WAS WELL ON
MY WAY INTO EARNING ANOTHER
DEGREE AT WHICH I JUST
COMPLETED THIS LAST SPRING SO
NOW I HAVE THREE COLLEGE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE AND I'M NOW
TRANSFERRING TO SAC STATE IN
THE FALL. TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON MY COMMUNICATIONS DEGREE AND
I CAN HONESTLY SAY THAT WITHOUT
REMARKS SCHOLARS PROGRAM THAT
IS BASICALLY THAT A PRECURSOR
TO THE RISING SCHOLARS PROGRAM
THAT IS BEING PROPOSED TODAY I
WOULDN'T BE WHERE I'M AT AND
I'M DEFINITELY THANKFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I AND I KNOW
THAT. MORE PEOPLE WILL TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT AND WILL- YOU
KNOW- FLOORS BECAUSE OF IT SO I
DEF- AND IT'S OF PASSING A
BEFORE SOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER DILLON NOWWE
NOW HAVE REBEKAH SOBERED SENIOR
DIRECTOR FROM RISING SCHOLARS
NETWORK ON THE LINE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH THAT THAT MANAGER
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- JUST
A FEW YEARS AGO THERE WAS VERY
LITTLE IN CALIFORNIA OR THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY OR
INCARCERATED OR- A FEW POCKETS
INCLUDING. ACTUALLY CHECKED AND
SHE- BUT NO COURT- IN-
CALIFORNIA. EIGHT MILLION
RESIDENTS BUT THE CONVICTION
HISTORY DISPROPORTIONATELY
PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND IT WAS THE
LAST GROUP FOR WHICH WE AT THE
STATE. OF PEOPLE THAT THE GDP.
FOR THEM AND THAT'S JUST NOT
TRUE ANYMORE THE CHANGES
STARTED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN. WE
NOW HAVE MORE THAN FIFTEEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS UNCOORDINATED
TRANSFERABLE DEGREE GRANTING
PATHWAYS IN PRISONS AND JAILS.
ALMOST FIFTY OF OUR COLLEGES
HAVE PROGRAMS LIKE REIMAGINE
SCHOLARS FROM CHRISTIAN DIDN'T.
THEY'LL HAVE PEER NETWORX
OUTREACH HELPING STUDENTS
MANAGE THE COMPLICATIONS THAT
ARISE. DURING OUR STUDENTS NEED
THESE COMMITTEE COLLEGE
PROGRAMS THEY EXPERIENCE
STATEMENT SAYING. THEY'VE LOST
TRACTION EDUCATION. OKAY
INTERESTING TO GET THE PORT
BUILDING COMMUNITY AWAY FROM
WHAT GOT THEM CURSORY DIDN'T
REAL THAT THEY CAN SUCCEED. IT
IS THIS IS WHAT MAKES CAL GREAT
THAT COLLEGES ARE. CAPITAL FOR
THE CLASS INCREASING STREETS
WITH EQUITY CAPS. IT IS
RECOVERY WITH EQUITY IS
INVESTING IN WHO NEED IT MOST
AND YOU OUR OUR AMAZING TO
SYSTEM JUST GOT THANK OF. CRIME
POVERTY EACH THE COLLEGES NEEDS
A. B. OR SEVENTEEN THERE WAS
ONE TIME FUNDING TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THAT HAVE GONE.
COLLEGES STAFFERS TERM CONTRACT
HE- DIDN'T DON'T KNOW THE KIND
BACK IT'S TIME TO INVEST IN AND
CREATE A STRUCTURE THAT THE
STATE AND THAT'S REALLY DESERVE
TO KNOW THAT E HAVE. QUALITY
AND WE CAN DO THAT. RIGHT WE
THAT JUST ABOUT DIDN'T CAN BE
ENORMOUS SIX. DEMANDS AND WE
KNOW HOW SURF THEM. AND WE ASK
THAT YOU PLEASE THE NEXT BY.
EIGHTY QUESTION. IN THE FUNDING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY.
MISSILE WELL NOW CAN TO OF
WITNESSES IN. OF A FORCE WILL
BEGIN WITH WITNESSES HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE. C.
NINE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
TWENTY FORTY WHICH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB AB FOUR
pWILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WANTING TO TESTIFY GEDIK
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
SEVENTEEN AND WILL BEGIN. FOR
PRESS ONE AND ZERO ONE. MISTER
MODERATOR WE CAN'T HEAR YOU. MY
APOLOGIES MY ANSWER WAS IN THE
WRONG POSITION IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR SEVENTEEN PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT
EIGHTEEN T. SPECIALIST WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. WHAT FIRST GO TO LINE
TWENTY SEVEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
I'M NOT ABOUT OTHER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COALITION AND
SUPPORT. BY. TWENTY NINE. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE SOVIET
POLICE SHOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
WORK AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE OFFICE OF
MAYOR LONDON BREED ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BLIND TWENTY
TWO. GOOD MORNING COULD YOU
KNOW WHENEVER WE HAVE TO THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY AND PART OF A
DIFFERENT. THANK YOU. LINE
THIRTY ONE. STEPHANIE GOLDMAN
ON BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND SUPPORT.
LINE THIRTY TWO. GOOD MORNING
SHARON MEMBERS JENNIFER POTS OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT- NINE
EIGHTEEN. HI GOOD MORNING AND
LEAVE THE CAR ON BEHALF OF YOU
SEE CERTAIN SITUATION WHERE I'M
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI
FOURTEEN FOUR ONE SEVEN THANK
YOU GREAT DAY. LINE THIRTY FIVE.
HI GOOD MORNING OUTLINING
SHATTENKIRK BOTTOM BEHALF OF
SENATE FOR CALIFORNIANS ME
COLLEGES WE ARE IN HI THE CORE
OF THE A B. OR SEVENTEEN THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIRMAN THERE ARE
NO OTHER LINES INTO. THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD MIND-CHECKING THE LINES ONE MORE
TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OF US
SUPPORT WITNESSES PLEASE. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER YOUR
SUPPORT YOUR SUPPORT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN WE HAVE NO IN
Q. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR.
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL THE
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
REGISTERED LEAD OPPOSITION IS
THAT CORRECT. PERFECT WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ANY WITNESSES WHO
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO FOR
SEVENTEEN HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. SCENE NINE. TO
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF TWENTY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. CNN THANK YOU I'M
ABOUT TO I WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY TO THE TELECONFERENCE
OR THIS. HOW MODERATE HE WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF FOUR SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTEEN WILL BE
KEPT. TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE QUEUED UP THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR MODERATOR- AND WE
WANT TO THANK ALL OF OUR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO OUR MEMBERS- WHICH IS A
LITTLE DIFFICULT RIGHT NOW.
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS ARE
ACTUALLY COMMITTEES SO WE WILL-
GIVEN OPPORTUNITY GIVE A
CLOSING REMARK IF YOU LIKE OKAY
THANK YOU CERTAINLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE RIGHT RIGHT NOW
AND- BUT- HOPEFULLY WE'LL GET A
QUORUM YOU CAN MOVE THIS ITEM
ON TO APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF A SUMMER
MCCARTY. THANK YOU. YES. THANKS
FOR TALKING WITH THE- ALLEN'S-
YEAH- THE. YOUR FOCUS- OKAY
THOSE WHO WERE TRYING TO GET A
HOLD OF YEAH I THINK SHE SHOULD
BE ON THE PROGRAM-
TWENTY. OKAY.
YEAH. OKAY. OKAY GOOD MORNING
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SAID WELL
KIRK SILVA WELCOME AND IT YOU
MAY AT AT WHEN YOU ARE READY AT
THE CENTER BILL. EIGHT FOUR
NINETY EIGHT GOOD MORNING MATT
AND CHAIR AND IT'S GREAT TO SEE
YOU HERE ON THE SENATE SIDE
HAVEN'T BEEN IN THIS ROOM IN
QUITE AWHILE. TODAY I'M
PRESENTING AB FOUR NINETEEN
EIGHT WHICH WILL CREATE THE
COMPUTER SCIENCE ACCESS
INITIATIVE DIRECTED AT
IMPROVING THE QUALITY AND
QUANTITY OF COMPUTER SCIENCE
EDUCATION IN SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. NOW WE ALL KNOW THAT
THIS LAST YEAR REALLY TESTED
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHERS AND
OTHER TEACHERS AND HOW WELL
THEY WERE ABLE TO WORK ONLINE
WE KNOW THAT SOME DISTRICTS
WERE WAY AHEAD. OF THE CURVE
ALREADY HAVING- USED- ONE ONE
COMPUTERS LAPTOPS IPADS- FOR
MANY YEARS AND OTHERS WERE
REALLY FORCED INTO IT. THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE GRANTS OF UP
TO TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER PARTICIPATING TEACHER TO
HELP PAY FOR THE TEACHERS COST
OF COURSE WORKBOOKS FEES AND
TUITION. AS A TEACHER MYSELF
FOR THIRTY YEARS I KNOW THAT
TRAINING. AND MORE TRAINING AND
MORE TRAINING IS REALLY THE KEY
TO BE AN EXCELLENT TEACHER I
MEAN THROUGHOUT THE YEARS I WAS
TRAINED IN GATE TICHINA ARE
GIFTED TEACHING I WAS TRAINED
IN LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT AND NOW
COMPUTER SCIENCE IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO. ASK OUR
TEACHERS TO BE TRAINED IN SO
THAT ACCESS TO EDUCATION
THROUGH ONLINE OR THROUGH
COMPUTER TECHNOLOGY IS
SOMETHING THAT IS BEYOND
IMPORTANT. THE OTHER BENEFIT OF
THIS BILL IS THAT AS OUR
STUDENTS AND MOVE ON AFTER. K.
TWELVE AND HIGHER ED AND INTO
THE WORK FORCE WE KNOW HAVING
THE BACKGROUND WITH TEACHERS
WHO HAVE TAUGHT THEM WELL WITH
COMPUTER SCIENCE WILL ALSO. BE
A GREAT ADDITION TO OUR
WORKFORCE AND IT'S EXACTLY WHY
ARE. PERSON THAT IS HERE TO
TESTIFY- ROBERT MODE TREAT THE
POLICY ADVOCATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF CONGRESS
IS SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND HAS
A FEW COMMENTS. THANK YOU
NUMBER AND GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE I'M SORRY I CAN'T BE
THERE WITH YOU I'M- I'M A
LITTLE UNDER THE WEATHER BUT
HOPEFULLY I'LL SEE YOU ALL
AGAIN SOON- YEAH OBVIOUSLY RUN
WHICH WE CALCHAMBER IN STRONG
SUPPORT EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
EIGHT AT ITS CORE WE THINK THAT
THE TEMPLE BELL. AT THE FLORIDA
CREEK GRANT HELP INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF TEACHERS WHICH
HOPEFULLY WILL HELP SPREAD
COMPUTER SCIENCE KNOWLEDGE INTO
THE FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA I
SHOULD ALSO NOTE THAT. WE THINK
IT'S VERY GOOD THAT THIS BILL
INCLUDES A PRIORITIZATION IN
THE GRANT FUNDING TO ADDRESS
EQUITY ISSUES BY SEEKING TO
IMPROVE AVAILABLE INSTRUCTION
IN TRADITIONALLY UNDER
REPRESENTED GROUPS TO THAT IN
THE COMPUTER SCIENCE FIELD. ON
THE ON THE EMPLOYER SIDE WITH
YOU THAT HE HELPING
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY IN THE
FUTURE AS THE FORMER NOTED
COMPUTER SCIENTIST.
INCREASINGLY MORE CENTRAL EVERY
DAY AND THE PANDEMIC AND THE
NEED TO PROMOTE LEARNING I
THINK MADE THAT EVEN MORE CLEAR
TO MANY OF A PARTICULAR. TO MY
TEACHER CURRENT- ALSO I SHOULD
NOTE THAT WE VIEW THE THAT THE
AS A WIN ON ALL COMPUTER
SCIENCE HEY WELL ENERGY EASY ON
THE BODY THAT MANY OF UP SO WE
THINK THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
HELPING TEACHERS TO AND IS THAT
SENSE- FOR THIS REASON WE-
SUPPORT AND- THANK. FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU MUCH ALL RIGHT
YOU WERE ONLY LEADS TO SO WE
WILL GO NOW TO FORTY TWO OH
THREE. SEEING NO ONE HERE WILL
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SIGNAL
ON A ROUTE TWENTY FORTY MISTER
MODERATOR CAN WE GO TO THE
ACTION HER THE MODERATOR
MODERATOR CAN WE HAD GO TO THE-
THE LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT. FOR A BI
FOR NINETY EIGHT. TO EXPRESS
YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI FOR
NINETY EIGHT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO
LINE THIRTY FOUR. GOOD MORNING
MANY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF
EDUCATION TRUST WHAT FOR THE
BILL. THANK YOU. THE OTHER THE
OTHER LINES QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE PROVIDE
THEIR LINE NUMBER. WE'LL GO TO
LINE FORTY. HELLO MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS ALEXIS
MINAKATA HERE AGAIN ON BEHALF
OF KOCO .ORG WE WANT TO THANK
THE BILL'S SPONSOR FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THE FELLOW
INTERNS HAVE DEPORTED. EIGHTY
FOUR NINETY EIGHT. PINE
FOURTEEN. GOOD MORNING AND
JOINING THE TEARS OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT. LINE.
SIXTEEN JOHN ON BEHALF OF
PROJECT LEAD THE WAY IN SUPPORT.
IT IS THERE ANY OTHER LINES
THAT WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BETTINGER WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP. THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR WILL NOW GO TO
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION- WE HAVE
NO LEAD OPPOSITION LISTED. IS
THERE ANYONE OF FORTY TWO OH
THREE SEEING NO ONE WILL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEING NO ONE
THERE MISTER MODERATOR CAN YOU
KILL ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO-
EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION TO AB
FOUR NINETY EIGHT PLEASE. TO
EXPRESS YOUR OPPOSITION PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BUT
AGAIN PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF
YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
MEASURE. MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE
KNOWN CHEWING UP AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- I AM VICE CHAIR YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. ARE VERY GOOD GOOD
MORNING ASSEMBLY WOMAN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I WOULD JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE VERY GOOD WE'RE JUGGLING A
LOT OF THINGS TODAY SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE WITH US-
MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE WE NEED
A MOTION. SALUTE MOTIONS BY
MADE BY. SENATOR OTOBO MA'AM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR NINETY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE OCHO ABODE HI
OTOBO GUIDE COURTESY. DALY
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN. WE WILL
LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL
ASSEMBLY WOMAN HAVE A GREAT
REST OF THE DAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
WELCOME I'M GOING TO TURN THE
GAVEL OVER TO MADAM VICE CHAIR
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS-
STUDENTS SHOULD BE PROTECTED
FROM AIR POLLUTION AND
HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES REGARDLESS
OF THE TYPE OF SCHOOL THEY
ATTEND AB SEVEN SIX TWO
REQUIRES PRIVATE AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO MEET THE SAME
SAFETY. REQUIREMENTS AS PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN CHOOSING A NEW
SCHOOL SITE I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE GROUP OF PARENTS AND
STUDENTS FOR MY DISTRICT WHO
HAVE BEEN SO SUPPORTIVE IN THIS
MEASURE IN MY DISTRICT A
PRIVATE SCHOOL CALLED STRATFORD
WAS BUILT RIGHT NEXT TO A
CONCRETE FACTORY. DOESN'T
CONTAMINANTS FROM THE FACT
BECAUSE OF DANGER TO HELP
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS ALIKE THE
STUDENTS SHOULD NOT HAVE TO PUT
THEIR HEALTH AT RISK BY GOING
TO CLASS WE HAVE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE THAT THE
BILL APPLIES TO PRIVATE AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO SEE WHAT. AB SEVEN
SIX TWO SIX TO PROTECT.
STUDENTS FROM AIR POLLUTION AND
DANGEROUS CHEMICALS ARE
STRICTLY ASKED FOR YOUR IPHONE
AND I WITNESSES ARE ALLEN APPS
FROM THE BAY AREA. BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND
LINSEED TO A FORMER SERVICE REP
FOR YOUR PHONE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MORNING MY NAME. OR
ANYTHING. I HAD A CREDIT
STRAFFORD SCHOOL ROOM FREMONT.
KINDERGARTEN WHEN I WAS IN
pNEXT TO A CONCRETE PLANT
KEEPING OUR WHICH CAUSE AIR
POLLUTION. HI DEBRA FOOTBALL
HAS THAT HAS GO IN I DON'T THE.
SOME AS MY OR OUR LARGER DOES
COULDN'T DO ANY OF ACT HE- I
THOUGHT I COULD BECAUSE IT DOES
WHAT'S BAD FOR. ALSO TO THANK
YOU FOR PC MY TEACHER AT THE
LOWER DECK BONTA HI WHICH A LOT
OF DIFFERENT FROM NIGHT I
CALLED. THE IN OF C. R. Y.
DRIVING PAST. HI PILOTS OF
CURRENT AND WITH. PREVENT OTHER
STUDENTS FROM HAVING TO GO
THROUGH WHAT I WENT. AB SEVENTY
SIX CAN ONE MAKE SURE THAT
SCHOOLS ARE NOT BUILT FOR. ANY
PROMOTION MY CONCRETE CURRENT
AND THAT STUDENTS AND TEACHERS
CAN LEARN AND TEACH IN STATE OF
THE ENVIRONMENT. I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AB SEVEN CLICK.
QUESTION NANTERRE IS A MISTAKE
COULD NOT CATCH TO ACCEPT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEEN
SUPER TODD MORNING BY. IS THIS
MR OUT MORNING VICE CHAIR OF
JOE BOGAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALAN ABBAS
ON THE LEGISLATIVE OFFICER WITH
THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT WHICH IS
THE PROUD SPONSOR OF AB SEVEN
SIXTY TWO AND WE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEAPERS LEADERSHIP IN
OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT BUILD
TECH CHILDREN OUT. IN CURRENT
LAW PRIOR TO CONSTRUCTING A NEW
PUBLIC SCHOOL OR PUBLICLY
FUNDED CHARTER SCHOOL SCHOOL
AUTHORITIES ARE REQUIRED TO
PERFORM SEVERAL ACTIVE DUE
DILIGENCE TO BETTER ENSURE THE
HEALTH OF THEIR FUTURE STUDENTS
AND SCHOOL STAFF. THEY
DETERMINE THAT THE PROPERTY TO
BE BUILT UPON IS NOT A CURRENT
OR FORMER HAZARDOUS WASTE SITE
OR HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES RELEASE
SITE AND THEY CONSULT WITH
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES AND
MAKE A FINDING THAT THE HEALTH
RISKS OR OTHER POLLUTION
SOURCES DO NOT AND WILL NOT
CONSTITUTE. AN ACTUAL OR
POTENTIAL ENDANGERMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. INCLUDES WORKING
WITH THE LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT TO IDENTIFY
BOTH PERMITTED AND NON
PERMITTED FACILITIES WITHIN
THAT DISTRICT AUTHORITY
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
FREEWAYS ANOTHER BUSY TRAFFIC
CORRIDORS LARGE AGRICULTURAL
OPERATIONS RAIL YARDS AND OTHER
SOURCES WITHIN ONE QUARTER OF A
MILE WHAT SCHOOL SITE. THIS IS
A REQUIREMENT THAT DOES NOT
CURRENTLY APPLY TO PRIVATE
SCHOOLS SOME CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND WHILE WE'RE NOT CLAIMING
THAT A LARGE NUMBER OF THE
SCHOOLS ARE POORLY CITED
INCREASING LAND USE DENSITY AND
RE PURPOSING INFILL SITES
RAISES THE POSSIBILITY THAT
WITHOUT SIMILAR DUE DILIGENCE.
FUTURE SCHOOLS MAY BE
CONSTRUCTED IN THE VICINITY OF
POLLUTION SOURCES THAT
UNNECESSARILY EXPOSE CHILDREN
IN SCHOOL EMPLOYEES. AND CREATE
AN UNHEALTHY WORK ENVIRONMENT.
A SEVENTY SIX TO RE THESE. TO
THE HAZARDOUS WAY IN NAPA.
CONDITIONS IN THE VICINITY OF
THE PROPOSED SCHOOL. KNOWLEDGE
THIS INFORMATION AND IF
NECESSARY TO USE IT IN THEIR
DECISION MAKING PROCESS WHEN
CONSTRUCTING THEIR SCHOOL. ON
BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
AGAIN THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEAVE FOR OFFERING THIS BILL
AND I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER UP'S WE WILL NOW GO IN
AT TWO ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
TO HEAR FROM ANY- ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF. AB. SEVEN SIX
TWO. SEIGNER WROTE MOVING INTO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. FIFTY NINE
THANK YOU NUMBER ONE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCES MISTER
MODERATE YOU WOULD PLEASE PUMP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN SIXTY
WILL BEGIN. TO REGISTER YOUR
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GO TO LINE.
FORTY ONE. TURNED OVER A COUNTY
SAN DIEGO AND TO PARK. BY THE.
FORTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MEMBERS
HERE AND MEMBERS PROSPECT WE ON
CAPS TOP CLOSED- THEIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
LINE. TWENTY FOR CALLING IN
FULL SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN TAKES
CARE. PINE. SIXTEEN PINE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD PLACE. PLEASE CHECK YOUR
MUTE FEATURE ON YOUR PHONE.
WILL BE GONE WILL GO TO ONE
THIRTY NINE. SHALL ONE YOU FOR
SUPPORT ALL SB. SEVEN SIXTY
TWO. ONE TWENTY FOUR. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS TOMMY LEE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION-
CAPITOLA REPRESENTING AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS FROM
ALL THIRTY FIVE- DISTRICTS IN
THE STATE CAPITAL IS IN A
STRONG SUPPORTER EIGHTY SEVEN
SIXTY TWO AND WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TO DO SO AS WELL. THANK YOU.
LINE. FOURTEEN ANGELINA GOOD
SHARED WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
SUPPORT. LINE. FORTY SIX. PINE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
CHECK YOUR MUTE FUTURE PLEASE.
WILL MOVE ON TO LINE SIXTEEN.
ON THE BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
YOUR SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. PINE FIFTY
TWO. MORNING MY NAME IS CRYSTAL
DIE ANOTHER FORMER TRUMP BIRDS
OF PARENTS AND I MEAN STOP THE
POOR TOP EIGHTY THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THANK YOU. NINE FORTY
SIX. NINE FORTY SIX YOU'VE
QUEUED UP PLEASE CHECK YOUR
HAND SAID- CHECK YOUR MUTE
FEATURE ON YOUR PHONE. MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR MURRAY
IF YOU MAY PLEASE CHECK ONE
MORE TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM ALL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF AB.
SEVEN SIX TWO. YES ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU ARE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WELL ONCE
AGAIN TIELINE FORTY SIX GO
AHEAD PLEASE- MAKING KERALA A
CURRENT PARENTS OF A STRAFFORD
SCHOOL I SUPPORT OF AB. SEVEN
SIXTEEN. ONE FIFTY FIVE. HELLO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN- HEAD PLEASE
OKAY THIS IS ETERNAL I PARK AB
SEVEN SIX TWO. HI KATE STARTED
AT STRATFORD. AT THE PASSCODE
SO THAT'S WHY I TOOK I KNOW ALL
THE INFORMATION ABOUT HERE.
THANK YOU. THE MANAGER WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE AND YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOT FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. LET'S MOVE ON TO
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN FORTY TWO
ALL THREE IN OPPOSITION I SEE.
PLEASE THANK YOU MADAM VICE
CHAIR AND- POLICIES ARE NOT
HAVING A TIRE WASN'T TESTED ARE
PLANNING ON TESTIFYING IN
PERSON BUT WE HAD A LITTLE MIX
UP WITH COMMITTEE SO APOLOGIES
FOR THAT- JOHN WHEN YOU'RE HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
SEVEN SIXTY TWO WE WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHORS OFFICE THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS FOR ALL THE ON GOING
DIALOGUE ON THIS BILL WE DID
HAVE A LOT OF BACK AND FORTH
AND RECEIVED- QUITE A BIT OF
CLARIFICATION ON SOME OF THE
AMENDED LANGUAGE. THAT WAS
TAKEN IN ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE
STILL BELIEVE THAT THE BILL AS
AMENDED IS OVERLY BROAD AND
OVERLY BURDENSOME ON OUR
CHARTER SCHOOLS- AS MANY FOLKS
KNOW OBTAINING ADEQUATE
FACILITIES HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
CHALLENGE FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS-
CHARTER SCHOOLS DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE SAME RESOURCES
THE DISTRICT PUBLIC SCHOOLS DO
SUCH AS LOCAL BINDING AUTHORITY
LOCAL ZONING EXEMPTIONS AND
EMINENT DOMAIN AUTHORITY- THERE
FOR CITING AND DEVELOPMENT OF
CIVILITY FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS
USES PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING
AND EXPENSIVE- WE BELIEVE
ADDING THAT NEW REQUIREMENTS
FROM THE ORIGINALLY PROPOSED
BUILT ON TOP OF THE NEWLY
ADDED- LEVEL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS UNDER SECTION.
SEVENTEEN TWO ONE TWO IN
ADDITION TO THE RIGOROUS LINK
THE LOCAL DEVELOPMENT APPROVAL
PROCESS SEES THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE TO GO THROUGH IS OVERLY
BURDENSOME AND UNNECESSARY DID
ACHIEVE THE ORIGINAL STATED
INTENT OF THIS BILL WHICH WAS
AROUND AIR QUALITY- CCSA
SUPPORTS ALL STUDENTS HAVING
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY SAFE AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY SOUND
EDUCATIONAL FACILITY HOWEVER
THIS CAN BE ACHIEVED WITHOUT
ADDING UNNECESSARY HURDLES TO
DEVELOPMENT THAT WILL FURTHER
LIMIT EDUCATIONAL ACCESS FOR
MANY OF OUR HIGH NEED STUDENTS.
WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT WE
BELIEVE ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATION IS NEEDED TO
PROTECT EXISTING SCHOOL
PROJECTS IN SCHOOLS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN ANY PART OF THE
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS- THE PRE
DEVELOPMENT OF FACILITIES TAKES
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS THAT WE
BELIEVE CHANGING THE RULES IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE PROCESS WILL
BE A SIGNIFICANT LOSS FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE ALREADY
INVESTING SIGNIFICANT RE- SAYS
PARTICULARLY IN THE MOST HIGH
NEED. AND HIGHLY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES THIS WILL RESULT
THE LACK OF ANY QUALITY
FACILITIES AND PROGRAMS IN
COMMUNITIES THAT NEED THE MOST
AND SO. FOR THOSE REASONS WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE- AB
SEVEN SIX TWO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN SIX TWO
IN A ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SCENE
NINE THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORBIS.
MR MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WILLING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVEN SIXTY WE
WILL BEGIN. SPEAKING OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE HAVE
A LINE IN CUBA WE PROVIDE THEIR
LINE NUMBER. WE WILL GO TO LINE
FIFTY GO AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO
HOW ARE AND WHAT THE CHARTER
SCHOOL DEVELOPMENT CENTER AND
WE REMAIN IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL FOR ALL OF THE REASONS
STATED IN OUR LETTER THANK YOU.
AND IF YOU WERE SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION ONCE AGAIN PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
BOETTICHER WE HAVE GOING QUEUED
UP AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MISTER MATTER IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND CHECKING LINES ONE MORE
TIME JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO AB. SEVEN SIX
TWO. AND IF YOU'D LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. MELCHER WE HAVE GROWN
QUEUING UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR MURRAY- AND THANK YOU TO ALL
OUR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL NOT BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR MEMBERS.
SENATOR GLAZERS. THANK YOU
CHAIR THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FINRA CONCERN IN THIS AREA IT'S
CERTAINLY A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO KEEP OUR KIDS SAFE.
FROM ANY KIND OF POLLUTION I
WAS INTERESTED IN HEARING FROM
YOUR SPONSOR THE BAY AREA AQ M.
D. ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED EXACTLY
IN THE FREMONT CASE FOR THAT-
THAT PERSON STILL ON THE LINE.
YES SENATOR- I AM OKAY BECAUSE
I THANK YOU IN. IS IT YOUR
TESTIMONY IT DID LEAVE ME A
LITTLE CONFUSED ABOUT HOW- THE
SIGHTING OF THE SCHOOL WHICH
WAS DONE BY THE CITY OF FREMONT
IS THAT CORRECT SIR. YES
SENATOR IT WOULD BE- THE
CITY'S- PLANNING DEPARTMENT.
OKAY AND IT WENT THROUGH A
SEQUEL AS IT WENT THROUGH A
SEQUEL PROCESS AS WELL. YES AND
SO THE SHORT VERSION OF THE
STORY IS THAT- IS THAT THE
STRATFORD SCHOOL PURCHASED LAND
FROM FROM PC ARE THAT- TCR WITH
THE SELLING. BUT THEY WERE
STILL MAINTAINING THEIR THEIR
PERMITTED FACILITY WHICH IT HAD
A DISTRICT PERMIT FOR ABOUT
THIRTY YEARS WHICH INCLUDED-
CONCRETE PLANT IN SAND AND
GRAVEL AND LANDSCAPING MATERIAL
BUSINESS WITH A LOT OF BUT-
DIESEL TRUCKS COMING IN AND OUT
OF THE FACILITY. AND ENDS SO-
THE STRATFORD SCHOOL WENT TO
THE PLANNING DEPARTMENT- AND
THEN WENT THROUGH THE SEQUEL
PROCESS. AND AT THE TIME IN- IN
STATE LAW. FOR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
THERE'S A REQUIREMENT THAT IS
PART OF ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW UP
FOR A- NEW SCHOOL CITING. THAT
THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICT HAVE TO
BE CONTACTED IN THE AIR
DISTRICT PROVIDES INFORMATION
ABOUT LOCAL PERMITTED SOURCES.
PART OF THAT BAYERN MENTAL
REVIEW PROCESS AND THAT THE
REQUIREMENT DOESN'T EXIST
OUTSIDE OF BUT A PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. SO STRATFORD UP WITH.
ENDED UP GOING THROUGH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW PROCESS
THROUGH THE CITY. WITHOUT
HAVING TO- WITHOUT HAVING TO DO
THAT- DUE DILIGENCE AND- ONLY
TO FIND OUT YOU KNOW ON THE
FIRST DAY AT SCHOOL WHEN THE
PARENTS BROUGHT THE KIDS TO
SCHOOL THAT- THAT THERE IS A
POTENTIAL ISSUE. THAT'S WHAT
LEAVES ME CONFUSED BECAUSE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL. QUALITY PROCESS.
IN THE FIVE CO A IT HAS IMPACT
RIGHT IT IT HAD TO HAVE AN
EXAMINING THAT DOCUMENT. THAT
ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSULTANT DIDN'T
REACH OUT TO YOU IN AND THAT
DURING THAT PROCESS. BUT NOT
FOR THAT PROCESS AND I AND I
GET A SENATOR I SHOULD I SHOULD
CLARIFY WHEN YOU DO-
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW ON A
PROJECT. YOU'RE YOU'RE LOOKING
AT THE EFFECTS OF THE PROJECT
ON THE OUTSIDE ENVIRONMENT AND
SO THE NORMALLY UNDER UNDER
SEQUEL UP. IF YOU WERE TO BUILD
A SCHOOL OR SOME OTHER FACILITY
YOU WOULD LOOK AT THE EFFECTS
ON THE ENVIRONMENT. DUE TO THE
CONSTRUCTION AND OPERATION OF
THAT FACILITY. AND THEN THERE
IS THE SO WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH PUBLIC SCHOOLS HOWEVER.
THERE'S THE THERE'S AN EXTRA
LITTLE KICKER IS PART OF THE
SEQUEL PROCESS WHERE YOU HAVE
TO LOOK INWARD- IN AND LOOK AT
THE EFFECTS OF THE OUTSIDE
ENVIRONMENT. ON THAT FUTURE
SCHOOL SITES IN THE IN THE WAY
IT'S GOING TO BE OPERATED IN SO
IT'S NOT- I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING BUT IT'S A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENT WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT PUBLIC SCHOOLS
VERSUS- BUT- TRADITIONAL UP
PROJECT THAT UNDERGO SPEAK
WHAT. ARE YOU TELLING ME THAN
THAT. YOU WERE NEVER AWARE OF
THIS PROJECT. NOT UNTIL NOT
UNTIL AFTER THE- THE SCHOOL
WITH THE WITH THE BILL AND IN
THE SCHOOL KIDS- CAME TO SCHOOL.
AND YOU THINK THAT VIOLATED ANY
PROCESS- THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE
FOLLOWED EITHER BY THE CITY OR
BY- THE- THE PROJECT PROPONENT
THREE SEQUEL. YEAH I'D I DON'T
THINK YOU KNOW CENTER I DON'T
THINK IT VIOLATED- IN ANYTHING-
BUT BUT I THINK. I THINK YOU
CAN. INDIAN GOOD PRACTICE SITE
I THINK THERE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
A LITTLE BIT MORE DUE DILIGENCE
PART OF THE- APPROVAL OF THE
SCHOOL IN THE FIGHTING BUT NO I
DON'T THINK THEY VIOLATED
ANYTHING IN PARTICULAR OKAY
AND- I AM A LITTLE. A LITTLE-
CONFUSED THAT THAT YOUR AGENCY
THAT'S MONITORING. THESE
ACTIVITIES THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE
REGION WOULDN'T BE AWARE OF THE
SCHOOL AND YOU TELL ME THAT YOU
HAD NO. AWARENESS THAT THE
SCHOOL WAS BEING PROPOSED AT
THE SITE THAT THAT YOU'RE
MONITORING OF CITY ACTIONS
PLANNING DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT
THE REGION. THAT YOU YOU HEARD
AND SAW NOTHING. ABOUT THIS
PROJECT. OUR IT DEPT THAT'S
CORRECT SENATOR IN AND- YOU
KNOW THE AND SO THE BAY AREA AQ
M. D. IS- IS A NINE COUNTY
AGENCY AND THERE'S A HUNDRED
CITIES AND NINE COUNTIES AND-
AND SO WE THERE ARE THOUSANDS
OF SPEAK WITH DOCUMENT. THAT
THAT- ARE ARE CREATED IN THE
BAY AREA REGION AND- AND SO
THIS WAS NOT SOMETHING THAT.
THAT WAS BROUGHT TO OUR
ATTENTION THAT WE NEED TO
PROVIDE COMMENTS ON NOW. OKAY
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THAT
INFORMATION. BY TO GO BACK TO
THE AUTHOR- ONE OF THE POINTS
THAT THE- THAT THE OPPOSITION
HAS RAISED IS THIS ISSUE OF. A
GRANDFATHER IN EXISTING CHARTER
PROJECTS THAT ARE UNDERWAY
RIGHT NOW COULD YOU COULD YOU
ADDRESS THAT R. AND FIRST A
SENEGALESE I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONCERN ABOUT. AIR
QUALITY DISTRICT I MEAN THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY OUR SHARE DECISIONS
IN THE BAY AREA AND I
UNDERSTAND. I TOO HAD THE
SUMMER CONCERNS HOW THIS
PROJECT EVEN EXISTED AND YES
THIS BILL WON'T FIX THE
PROBLEMS THAT ALREADY EXISTED
THE SHEPHERD SCHOOL
FORTUNATELY. BUT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO IS PROSPECTIVELY MAKE
SURE NO KID EVER GOES TO SCHOOL
AFTER THE BILL ON A DATE OR
SITE- THAT IS WHY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE TAKING
GRANDFATHERING CLAUSE. BECAUSE
IT THERE SHOULD BE NO. I DON'T
KNOW IF DOUBT OF WHETHER AND
YOU SEND YOUR KID TO IT IN FOR
A- NOTHING IT BUT A TOXIC SITE
OF ANY SORT AND WE DON'T WANT
TO MAKE THIS. ANY LESS MISTRUST
EXAMPLES I DON'T WANT TO HAVE
ANYMORE THOSE CASES AND THERE
ARE CASES OF COURSE NOW THERE'S
A SOUTHEAST L. A. SCHOOL THAT
IS ALSO BUILT LIKE ON TOP OR
NEXT ARSENIC AS WELL AS OTHER
EXAMPLES EASIER ACROSS THE
STATE. WE DON'T WANT THAT TO BE
HAPPENING ANYMORE. RIGHT BUT
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT IF THEY
HAVE FOLLOWED THE EXISTING
LAWS. OF THE STATE AND THEY
HAVE. RAISED THE CAPITAL. AND
THEY'RE UNDERGOING CONSTRUCTION
RIGHT NOW AFTER GETTING ALL THE
PERMITS ENVIRONMENTAL. BUILDING
CODES ETCETERA. IF YOU'RE GONNA
TAKE A BILL LIKE THIS AND
YOU'RE GOING TO POTENTIALLY
UNRAVEL THE IRRESPECTIVE OF
WHETHER THERE'S AN ISSUE OR
NOT- ALL THOSE AND ANY PROJECT
LIKE THAT. YEAH AS MR ABBAS
SPOKE ABOUT YOU KNOW THE NORMAL
CYCLE PROCESS FOR DEVELOPMENT
REALLY LOOKS AT EXTERNALITIES
ARE PROJECT HOW THE PROJECT
IMPACTS. THE SURROUNDINGS FOR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ONLY RIGHT NOW
IT LOOKS ABOUT HOW THE
EXTERNALITY OF OUR IMPACT THE
SCHOOL THAT DOESN'T EXIST FOR
PRIVATE CHARTERS AT THE MOMENT
AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ALIGN-
AND I OF COURSE UNDERSTAND IT
WOULD- PERHAPS BECAUSE SOME
DIFFICULTIES BUT I THINK IT'S
AN IMPORTANT STEP TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE STE. THE THAT THE IRA
THE VIRUS SAFE FOR THE STUDENTS
AND NOT JUST OF THE SCHOOLS AS
SAFE FOR THE ENVIRONMENT ON IN
AND WHY NOT MAKE THIS
REQUIREMENT FOR ANY
CONSTRUCTION CALIFORNIA THAT
THAT'S GONE ON NOW OR- IN THE
FUTURE WEARING WHITE WHY
ISOLATING JUST PRIVATE CHARTER
SCHOOLS HERE AND WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING FOR. I THINK IT'S ABOUT
CONCERNED BUT OUR BILL AS
HOPEFULLY ALIGNING RIGHT NOW
TRYING TO LINE THE SAFETY
STANDARDS OF ALL SCHOOLS OR THE
PRIVATE CHARTER OR PUBLIC SO
THAT'S THE SCOPE OF OUR BILL
RIGHT NOW BUT HAPPY TO EXPLORE
THAT OPTION FUTURE THE CENTER.
BECAUSE IT SEEMS THAT PART OF
THE ISSUE HERE IS- THE ASSETS
PRIVATE CONSTRUCTION RIGHT NO
PUBLIC DOLLARS BEING USED.
WHICH WOULD APPLY TO PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE YOU'RE
TRYING TO MAKE THIS BILL
APPLICABLE TO WRITE YOUR BILL
DOESN'T SAY- THIS IS GOING TO
APPLY ONLY TO CHARTER SCHOOLS
THAT RECEIVE PUBLIC DOLLARS. I
THINK IF YOU DID IT THAT WAY
THEN I UNDERSTAND WHY YOU
WOULDN'T. BE INTERESTED IN
EXPANDING EXPANDING IT MORE
BROADLY I MEAN IS YOUR
ATTENTION TO HAVE IT APPLY TO
CHARTER. SCHOOLS THAT USE NO
PUBLIC FUNDS. WELL I A- I
BELIEVE THE- SCHOOLS ARE NOW IN
SUPPORT OF OUR BILL AFTER WE
CLARIFIED TO THE AMENDMENTS
BEING THE PRIVATE PRIVATE
SCHOOL WHICH OBVIOUSLY A 100%
PRIVATE THROUGH AND THROUGH
WHICH ONLY RECEIVE. PUBLIC
EDUCATION DOLLARS FOR THE
OPERATION. OUR SUPPORT OF IT
NOW AND I THINK IT'S WITHIN THE
ALIGNMENT THAT WE JUST WANNA
KEEP OUR SCHOOLS I TENER KID
SAFE NO MATTER WHAT SCHOOL TO
GO TO. RIGHT BUT I'M ASKING
ABOUT IF PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE
BEING USED TO CONSTRUCT THIS IS
ABOUT CONSTRUCTION NOT THE
OPERATION RIGHT. SO IF PUBLIC
DOLLARS AREN'T BEING USED FOR
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE SCHOOL
SITE. DO YOU INTEND REALLY TO
MAKE YOUR BILL APPLICABLE TO
THAT. THAT SITUATION AS WELL
AND IF IT IS TO ASK YOU WHY YOU
WOULDN'T WANT TO MAKE IT. MORE
BROADLY TO INCORPORATE ANY KIND
OF PRIVATE- INVESTMENT AND
CONSTRUCTION ANYWHERE IN THE
STATE. WELL AS THE BILL APPLIES
IN A PLACE TO PRIVATE SCHOOLS
BOB SO THAT ALSO COMPLETE
PRIVATE CONSTRUCTION- I MEAN
I'M HAPPY TO EXPLORE THE OPTION
OF MORE. CHECKS ON A BOB. AS WE
KNOW WITH OUR HOUSING CRISIS
RIGHT NOW HOW MANY HURDLES WE
NEED TO. PUT INTO CONSTRUCTION
OF. ALL THE THINGS I MEAN IT'S
A I THINK IT'S A TOPIC FOR
ANOTHER DAY. PROPS BUT I'M
INTERESTED IN THIS FIELD WORK
OUT TOGETHER. WELL I THINK THAT
THAT LOOKED AT- I WANT TE
STANDARDS TO BE IN PLACE I WANT
TO PROTECT THEIR KIDS I WANT TO
PROTECT EVERYBODY. AND IT IT
DOES IT REMAIN SURPRISING TO ME
THAT. THE BOARDS ARE NOT
CONSULTED IN THE S. SEQUEL
PROCESS THAT GOES ON THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND WHATEVER
CONSTRUCTION. AYE THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED UHHUH- I'M TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT TRYING
TO TREAT. ONE ONE SLICE OF THE
CONSTRUCTION WORLD WHICH IS
PRIVATE CHARTERS WITHOUT PUBLIC
DOLLARS. DIFFERENTLY THAN THE
AND- ALL THOSE OTHRS I'M JUST
TRYING TO CREATE SOME
CONSISTENCY. YOU RECOGNIZE
INFECTED YOU. GET COMMON MOMENT
AGO. TALKED ABOUT THE
REGULATION. THE AD AND I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
DUPLICATIVE. THIS IS ALREADY
BEING CAPTURED- IN PRIVATE
CONSTRUCTION THROUGH THE SEQUEL
PROCESS. WHY DOES IT HAVE TO BE
WHAT IT HAVE TO BE ISOLATED OUT
IN YOUR BILL AND MAYBE THERE'S
JUST NO REASON FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN. HAPPENED BEGIN YOUR
BILL THAT WAY. FOR PRIVATE
CONSTRUCTION WITHOUT PUBLIC
DOLLARS. THAT'S WHY I
APPRECIATE THE CLARIFICATION.
WELL I MEAN I OF ALSO
UNDERSTAND AND THE SENSE OF
CONSISTENCY BUT I THINK IF IN
THE SCOPE OF A BILL IT APPLIES
TO PRIVATE CONSTRUCTION PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION. OR IN BETWEEN FOR
CHARTERS SO THAT'S I THINK
WE'LL RECYCLE IT AND WE'RE
MAINTAINING ITS ABOUT SCHOOLS
RIGHT NOW. AND THAT'S THE SCOPE
ARE BILL. OKAY I DO BELIEVE
IT'S- AYE AYES I THINK IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH ANALOGIC MARBLE.
OKAY I WANT TO SEE- DEVICE
YEARS PASSED THE GAVEL BACK
THIS OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU RICHARD. FIRST OFF I WANT
TO SAY SOMEBODY WHO CAME OUT OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENT SIXTEEN YEARS
AND- WORKED WITH AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICTS AND ALSO. WAS
SECRET AND WE CAN TALK ABOUT
SECRET. CALIFORNIA IS THE MOST.
WHO WE HAVE THE MOST
REGULATIONS IN TRYING TO PROVE
A PART PROJECT PROBABLY
ANYWHERE IN THE NATION AND
THERE MAY BE SOME PLACE THAT
DOES IT MORE BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT WE- WE'RE BEHIND IN THIS
AREA. THIS BILL APPEARS TO BE
YOU KNOW PUTTING PRIVATE VERSUS
PUBLIC IN AND BASICALLY TRYING
TO GO AFTER CHARTERS WHAT I SEE
I MEAN IF YOU LOOK AT THIS IF
I'VE AS I'VE MENTIONED BEFORE.
I LIKE SEQUEL ACTUALLY SECRET
REGIONAL DESIGNER SEQUEL IS TO
MITIGATE IMPACTS IF YOU'RE
BUILDING SOMETHING DOESN'T
MATTER IF YOU'RE PRIVATE OR
PUBLIC YOU STILL HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS. AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. IN THIS BILL IS
SPLITTING HAIRS AND WE
OBVIOUSLY KNOW THAT IT'S GOING
AFTER. YOU KNOW PRIVATE AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND THERE SOME
PEOPLE WHO DON'T LIKE THOSE AND
SO. AND WHEN YOU WERE USING THE
ENVIRONMENT AS A TOOL SO FOR ME
I'M AND I'M NOT SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY AND I WILL SHARE
WITH YOU WE'VE DONE A BUNCH OF
A SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS IN HERE TO
TRY TO GET THINGS DONE BECAUSE
WE CAN'T BUILD THINGS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ON TOP OF THAT
THIS BILL IS GOING TO IMPACT
THOSE WHO WENT THROUGH THE PAST
TO GET SENATORS RECOGNIZED HAVE
ALREADY. IS WHAT THE PROCESS
THEY THEY'VE- THEY'VE DONE WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO. THROUGH
SEQUEL AND THE LOCAL ORDINANCES
THAT THEY HAVE. AND THIS BILL
WILL CHANGE THE GAME IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE PROCESS AND I
DON'T THINK THAT'S FAIR TO
THEM. AND I THINK THAT THERE'S
PLENTY OF REGULATORY LAWS- IN
CALIFORNIA THAT SAFEGUARD. OUR
STUDENTS AND OUR PRIVATE AND
ARE QUITE FRANKLY OUR
BUSINESSES SO FOR THOSE REASONS
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY. I THANK YOU CENTER I
DON'T SEE ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM OTHER MEMBERS. I
DO WHEN I COME BACK AND SOME UP
SOME OF MY COMMENTS THAT. WHICH
IS THAT. I DO THINK THERE'S
SOME ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THESE
TYPES OF- MISTAKES THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE AND THE STRATFORD
SCHOOL AS AN EXAMPLE OF WHERE.
YOU HAD LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS. THAT WERE HAD THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF REVIEWING
THAT PROJECT APPLICATION. AND
REVIEWING ALL THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTS AND MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYTHING WAS. WAS TOGETHER
AND RIGHT AND SAFE AND- AN
APPROPRIATE AND- SO WHEN YOU
HAVE A- AND SO FOR ME THERE'S A
BREAK DOWN THERE. AND THERE
THERE SHOULD BE ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THAT THE QUESTION REALLY IS
WHETHER OR NOT. THAT ONE
EXAMPLE IN THE STATE SHOULD BE
USED TO CREATE A BROAD
SWEEPING. OBLIGATION AS
PROPOSED IN YOUR BILL AND
THAT'S THE CHALLENGE THAT I
HAVE HAD I. I THINK THAT IF
YOU- APPLIED IT TOO IF YOU
DIDN'T HAVE A GRANDFATHER IN
THERE. AND IF YOU- TOOK OUT
PRIVATELY FUNDED PROJECTS WHICH
IN ESSENCE IF YOU DON'T HAVE
PUBLIC DOLLARS THAT COULD BE
ANY PROJECT. BUT IN THIS CASE A
SCHOOL PROJECT I THINK. IT'S A
PLACE THAT I THINK YOU'D GET MY
SUPPORT. BECAUSE I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS GOOD I
THINK YOU HAVE THE BEST OF.
GOALS IN YOUR BILL AND DIED I'D
LIKE TO SEE IT- COME TO
FRUITION AND THAT'S THAT'S THE
CHALLENGE FOR ME AT THIS POINT
IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU'RE
PRESENTING ALEX. GIVE YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY ANYTHING
FURTHER INTO CLOTHES IF YOU
WISH. I'LL CLOSE. OUT I JUST
WANNA SAY I REALLY THINK
CENTERS ARE BRING UP THE
CONCERNS ARE VERY VALID
CONCERNS BUT- YOU KNOW
ULTIMATELY. EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
THESE PROCESSES IN THESE LAWS
RIGHT NOW OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE
FEELING AS THEIR FAILING OUR
KIDS. AND YOU CAN BET THAT IF
THERE WAS A PUBLIC SCHOOL WITH
THE SAME SITUATION THAT
DESCRIBES GOING DISTRICT
HAPPENED IT WILL BE UP IN ARMS.
BUT THIS SCHOOL STRAFFORD IS
NOT THE ONLY EXAMPLE THERE'S A
SCHOOL IN SOUTHEAST L. AID LIKE
I MENTIONED THAT IS ALSO BEING
BUILT ON OR NEAR ARSENIC IS
SMALL. AND IT WAS A GREAT NBC
INVESTIGATIVE PIECE THAT SHOW
JUST HOW MANY SCHOOLS LIKE TO
ACTUALLY OUT THERE. AND THERE
REALLY WASN'T NOBODY UNTIL.
THAT I KNOW OF UNTIL THIS
INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALIST PIECE
CAME OUT WHICH IS AFTER THE
STRATFORD CASE THOUGH- THAT
SHOW THE IMMENSE SCALE THIS
WHERE THERE COULD BE SO MANY
PUBLIC PRIVATE. AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT COULD BE BUILT
NEAR THIS CONTAMINATION SITES.
AND THE QUESTION IS WITH THIS
BILLS DO WE WANT MORE OF THOSE
THINGS. IS CLEARLY THE CURRENT
PROCESSES ARE FAILING US IN A
FAILURE STUDENTS. I DO THINK
THAT PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE NOW
HAVE AN- HAVE A- HIGH STANDARD
OF PROOF TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
SCHOOLS AND OUR KIDS ARE SAFE.
I KNOW WHAT I WANT TO DO IS
BRING. SCHOOLS OF ANY SORT TO
THAT SAME ALIGNMENT WHETHER THE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS WHICH I REALLY
THANK THEM FOR SUPPORTING MY.
BILL OR PROP OUR CHARTER
SCHOOLS WHICH HAVE EITHER POP.
FUNDS OR- PRICE. YOU KNOW. I
THINK WE ARE ALL ON THE SAME
PAGE THAT WE HAVE TO PROTECT
OUR STUDENTS FROM THESE AROUND
HAZARDS AND CLEARLY THAT'S WHAT
I'M SAYING IS THERE'S JUST. A
GAP GAP IN THE HOLDS THAT
EXISTS NOW. CERTAINLY THERE
SHOULD BE MORE. I KIND OF
REALLY LOOKING INTO WHY PASS
EXAMPLES HAPPENBUT LOOKING
PERSPECTIVE IN THE FUTURE. WE
NEED TO PROTECT OUR KIDS I
THINK THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
APPROACH TO PROVE IT. THAT'S
WHERE PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
PRIVATE SCHOOLS SUPPORTING A
FORTUNE WE HAVEN'T. REACHED
AGREEMENT WITH THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS YET BUT AT LEAST YOU
HAVE TO A THREE. AND- I THINK
THAT'S PRETTY GOOD SO I HEARD
SHE- YOU'RE EITHER AND THANK
YOU FOR THE DISCUSSION. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER- WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF OUR MEMBERS HERE
AT THE MOMENT SO I THINK WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION WHEN ARCA
COMMITTEES BACK TOGETHER. THANK
YOU FOR PRESENTING. OKAY. WE'RE
GONNA GO TO- THAT THE LAST- THE
PRESENTATION OF A BOOK TO OUR
CONSULTANT THERE'S ONE MORE
BILL ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENT IS
THAT RIGHT AND HE'S HERE I GOT
A APPEARS. LIKE MAGIC. WE'RE A-
AS A LOT OF TAG TEAM GOING ON
HERE TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH
ALL THAT'S GOING ON SO I NEED
TO THE ACTING OF THE ACTING
CHAIR. AT THE MOMENT. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE YOU'RE
PRESENTING AB ELEVEN ELEVEN
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. AND WE
WELCOME YOUR PRESENTATION THANK
YOU A SENATORS AND MAKE THIS AS
QUICK AS POSSIBLE AB ELEVEN
ELEVEN WILL CREATE A COMMON
COURSE NUMBERING SYSTEM AT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
MEANING COMPARABLE COURSES
WOULD HAVE THE SAME COURSE
NUMBER AT ALL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AS THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT CAN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS TAKE
COURSES AT MULTIPLE COLLEGES
WITHIN A DISTRICT OR EVEN
ACROSS DISTRICTS WITHOUT A
COMMON COURSE NUMBERING SYSTEM
IT IS HARDER FOR STUDENTS TO
PLAN OUT A COHERENT ROADMAP.
TURNING THEIR DEGREE
DIFFERENCES IN COURSE NUMBERS
CAN UNINTENTIONALLY SET
STUDENTS BACK SERVING AS A
BARRIER TO TIMELY TRANSFER. IN
FEBRUARY THE GOVERNOR'S
RECOVERY WITH EQUITY TASK FORCE
POLICE TO REPORT WHICH INCLUDED
A SET OF RECOMMENDATIONS AIMED
AT HELPING CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS RECOVER FROM
THE PANDEMIC ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IS TO DEVELOP A
COMMON COURSE NUMBERING SYSTEM
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES. SO
THAT STUDENTS TRANSFERRING TO
FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS KNOW AS
THEY ARE PURSUING THEIR COURSES
THAT THEY ARE MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS. THIS BILL IS
BASED ON THIS COMMONSENSE
RECOMMENDATION HAVING THE SAME
COURSE NUMBER FOR COMPARABLE
COURSES AT ALL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WOULD REDUCE
UNNECESSARY CONFUSION. HE'S
ADVISING REDUCE EXCESS CREDIT
CANNULATION TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR STUDENTS TO TRANSFER AND
EARN THEIR DEGREE SAVING
STUDENTS BOTH TIME AND MONEY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY ARE JUST
MEAN THAT JASMINE PRASAD. VICE
PRESIDENT OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR THE STUDENT SENATE
FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND JESSE RYAN
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND- MODERATOR WILL GO
TO YOUR- TELEPHONE LINE IS THAT
WHERE I UNDERSTAND THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE AND IF YOU
COULD ANSWER LIKE THE BILL TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY I THINK WE
HAVE. A TWO MINUTE LIMIT. FOR
EACH SO WE WELCOME THE
TESTIMONY NOW. GOOD MORNING
CARE LATE THEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ACTUALLY AND GOOD
MORNING SENATOR GLAZER WE
APPRECIATE YOU STEPPING. CENTER
LATE ABSENT. THE RYAN EXECUTIVE
RIGHT BY PRESIDENT OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY. A NONPROFIT
DEDICATED TO ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
TRICKS AND DIDN'T SUCCEED IN
COLLEGE. I'M ALSO A PROUD
FORMER COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TRANSFER STUDENT. REPRESENTING
PART OF AN ASTONISHING LESS
THAN 3% OF STUDENTS THAT WILL
SUCCESSFULLY REACH THEIR
TRANSFER GOALS WITHIN TWO YEARS
OF ENTERING A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE- LOW INCOME FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS LIKE
MYSELF. CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE THE GATEWAY TO
OPPORTUNITY. AND IMPROVED
ECONOMIC OUTCOMES. THEY ALSO
SERVE A CRITICAL FUNCTION IN A
DAMPING EDUCATIONAL EQUITY FOR
THE LARGE BLACK IN LATIN ACT
YOU CAN POPULATIONS THEY
SUPPORT. MANY STUDENTS WHO ARE
SEEKING TO DEFY THE ODDS AND
TRANSFER WITHIN TWO YEARS OFTEN
CONCURRENTLY ENROLL IN CLASSES
THAT SPAN ACROSS MULTIPLE
COLLEGES. AND EVEN MULTIPLE
DISTRICTS AND IN ATTEMPT TO
EXPEDITE THEIR PROGRESS TOWARDS
ACHIEVING TRANSFER EARNING A
DEGREE. I ACTUALLY WENT TO TAX
CITY AMERICAN RIVER AND CONSUME
THAT SIMULTANEOUSLY TO GET THE
CLASSES I NEEDED TO REACH MY
COLLEGE DREAM. TAKING A CLASSES
ACROSS CAMPUSES COULD BE
DESCRIBED AS MANY THINGS. THE
NATION'S AMBITIONS ARE DRIVEN.
AB ELEVEN ELEVEN SEEKS TO LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD FOR THE
MAJORITY OF STUDENTS TO
DESCRIBE THE CURRENT PROCESS.
USING INEFFECTIVE AND COSTLY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
MENTIONED IN HIS REMARKS THE
EDUCATIONAL INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOP THREE C. ID IS
RECOGNISED IN AB ELEVEN ELEVEN.
BUT C. R. U. D. AS IS DOESN'T
GO FAR ENOUGH TO CREATING A
TRULY STUDENT CENTERED PROCESS.
FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE SEEKING TO
DETERMINE IF OF COURSE THAT ONE
COLLEGE IT'S A CLICKABLE TOWARD
THEIR EDUCATIONAL. GOALS IN
ANOTHER THEY SHOULDN'T NOT HAVE
TO DO DOWN AND- MULTI CA NUMBER.
ORYX BY ON CAMPUS HE TRACK OF
COURSE CATALOG THE CAR MALL AND-
IT'S RAISES THE RISK OF
UNNECESSARILY REPEATING
CLASSES. FOR DECADES OUR SYSTEM
HAVE DEBATED COMMON COURSE
NUMBER. AND AS A RESULT THEY
DESIGN PROCESSES THAT LARGELY
WORK FOR INSTITUTIONS THAT
MISSED THE MARK FOR STUDENTS.
WE HAVE TO SAY THAT COMMON
COURSE NUMBERING IS A STUDENT
CENTERED IDEA AT THAT TIME HAD
COME SH THE GOVERNOR'S RECOVERY
WITH EQUITY TASK FORCE
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEED FOR COMMON
COURSE NUMBER EIGHTEEN AND
THEIR RECOMMENDATION. THE
SENATE ASSEMBLY AND GOVERNOR
HAVE ALLOCATED TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF
COMMON COURSE NUMBERING. IN
SHORT WE KNOW THAT COMMON
COURSE NUMBER IN ITS BOTH A
BEST PRACTICE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND THAT INSTITUTION'S
LIKE LOS RIOS COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT THE SECOND LARGEST
DISTRICT IN THE STATE. RADWAY
EXACTLY INSTITUTING COMMON
COURSE NUMBERING ACROSS THEIR
COLLEGES FOR VERY LITTLE COST
TRYING TO THINK IT'S UNLIMITED
DEFIED THE TRANSFER PROCESS FOR
STUDENTS. I STRONGLY URGE
ARRIVA THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS
RYAN- THIS PRASAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING SENATOR AUDIBLE TO
MEMBER MY NAME IS JOHN AND I'M
THE VICE ELECT PACKAGE DIDN'T
CALIFORNIA'S RAINY COLLEGES. MY
PURPOSE HERE TODAY IS TWO FOLD
FIRST RELAY HOW PROUD WE ARE TO
SPONSOR AB ELEVEN ELEVEN AND
ALSO SHARE WITH YOU HOW MEANT
THREE IMPORTANT THIS VILLAGE
IN. CLEANLY THIS IS A BILL THAT
COULD HAVE GIVEN A LOT OF TIME
MONEY AND ENERGY I WAS
FORTUNATE TO ATTEND LET'S. MAKE
COLLEGE DISTRICT THAT IS THE
ONLY DISTRICT THAT I KNOW OF
THAT IMPLEMENTED COMMON CORE
NUMBER. EVEN THOUGH I TEND TO
AGREE TO ME COLLEGES WITHIN THE
DISTRICT BECAUSE THE COMMON
COURSE NUMBERING I WAS ABLE TO
STAY ON A CLEAR TRANSFERABLE
PASS. AND NOT WORRY ABOUT
WHETHER I WOULD UNINTENTIONALLY
REPEAT A CORD. MISSPELLING GIVE
ALL COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
THE SAME BENEFIT REPEATING
COURSES AS A RESULT NOT GETTING
TRANSFER CREDIT FOR THOSE
COURSES HAD HAPPENED. MORE THAN
ONCE I'M WITH ONLY A
HUMILIATING ACCESS UNIT. KALENA
TRANSFER AND NEGATIVELY
IMPACTING THEIR FINANCIAL AID
AND THERE FOR COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY. EVEN GRANTED ARE
DISADVANTAGED I RECONNECTED IS
NOT HOW THE CALLING CARD NUMBER
AND- A VICE PRESIDENT OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS WITH ME
COLLEGE SYSTEM I HEAR WAY TOO
OFTEN OF HOW STUDENTS HAVE BEEN
STUCK IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. ALONG HERE AND ARE AT
THE BRINK OF DROPPING OUT BEACH
THIS PRECISE ISSUE. OFTENTIMES
THE STUDENTS ARE MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES DEMONSTRATING THAT
THIS ISN'T THIS IS AN EQUITY
ISSUE. AND NOT BEING I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AND I THE FOR
AB ELEVEN ELEVEN BECAUSE IN
DOING SO YOU'RE GOING TO FIND
THE TRANSFER PROCESS FOR ALL
STUDENTS THANK YOU. THANK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION IN THE
HEARING TODAY. LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S OTHER SUPPORTERS HERE
IN THE ROOM. I DON'T SEE ANY
WILL GO TO A REMOTE LOCATION DO
NOT SEE ANYONE THERE FACT
MODERATOR CAN YOU A Q. ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE TO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. I REMIND
THOSE WHO DO WHO DO THAT WE'RE
JUST ASKING AT THIS POINT HERE
IN THE PROVIDE YOUR NAME. AND
YOUR AFFILIATION OF ANYTHING ON
YOUR. SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
MODERATOR PLEASE. THANK YOU TO
READ AS A- FOR A BI ELEVEN
ELEVEN THESE. ONE THEN OF THIS
TIME. WE WILL GO TO LIVE H.
WHAT PLAYERS. HI MY NAME IS
EMILY THE CARD BEHALF OF THE U.
STUDENTS HAVE. WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORTER THE BILL THANK YOU
MUCH NEXT. FINE SIR. KILLING
JOHN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL COUNSELORS THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY FOR COLLEGE
ADMISSION COUNSELING AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF IB
WORLD SCHOOLS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE TWELVE. GOOD
MORNING TRANSIT GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE OFFICE ON THE
TRAIN A GOVERNOR'S ISLAND YOU
CAN UNLOCK IT I THINK ON THING
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FINE.
FIFTY FOUR. HELLO MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY WILL AND I'M A
REPRESENTATIVE CHEN UP WHICH IS
THE USE EDUCATION ACT THE TO AN
EFFICIENT WITH OVER FOUR
THOUSAND MEMBERS I'M ALSO
CONSTITUENTS THAN IT COULD NINE
AND I WOULD LIKE TO AVOID MY
PASSION SUPPORT FOR AB ELEVEN
ELEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT OPERATOR. IS THERE
ANY LINE IF THERE ARE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THIS IS YOUR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
OPPOSITION TO THIS LEGISLATION
HERE FROM THEM NOW IS THERE
ANYONE WE DON'T HAVE A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS ANYONE HERE
IN. IN FORTY TWO OH THREE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION C. NINE
WILL GO TO OUR REMOTE LOCATION.
C. NINE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES ARE MODERATED WOULD YOU
QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE. IN
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONCE AGAIN PLEASE TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY NOW TO PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO TO EXPRESS YOUR
OPPOSITION. THIS TEACHER WE
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THREE AFFECT
WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
DISCUSSIONS MOTIONS THE BILL
CENTER DOLLY HAS MOVED THE
BILL. I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE
THAT AND ASK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN OUT OF ME TO SAY
IT'S A GREAT BILL I JUST THINK
GUYS. HERE TO NATIONS IN
CONTINUING THE LEGACY OF OTHER
MEMBERS WHO REALLY WANT TO MAKE
COLLEGE- NOT JUST AFFORDABLE
AND ACCESSIBLE BUT
UNDERSTANDABLE AND TRANSFERABLE
AND ALL THOSE THINGS THAT ALL
ALLOWED KIDS TO SUCCEED AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THAT AREA WALKING TO CLASS. I
COULDN'T DO BETTER CLOSING THAT
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AND
YOUR KIND WORDS THANKS SO MUCH
FOR SUCCESS FROM ABOUT. PIC IF
THE AND CONSULT WITH COULD CALL
THE ROLL PLACE. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN A. B. ELEVEN
ELEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR LEYVA. OCHO ABODE FOR
TENNESSEE DALLI. DALLI AYE
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE. MCGUIRE
PAN. WE ARE WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE SODAS ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
WE DON'T HAVE A FULL COMMITTEE
I THINK WE WILL. AND IT'S UP
BUT YOUR BILL- IS LOOKING GOOD
SILVER SHOULD STAY STAY TUNED.
NOT MUCH WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IT
WELL IS JUST TO GO BACK THROUGH
THE- THE BILLS THAT WE HAVE
HEARD IF THAT'S OKAY- MY SHARE
IS ARRIVED BACK SHE'S WELCOME
TO TAKE THAT OVER- SHE WISHES.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE IN THE
HEARING PROCESS WE DO NOT HAVE
A MOTION YET. ON ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN SIXTY TWO BY LEE THE
OTHERS I BELIEVE MOTIONS HAVE
BEEN MADE. WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
A MOTION MCCARTY OKAY. SO DO WE
NEED A MOTION FOR SEVENTEEN
ABC. YES CONSERVATIVE. YES
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT OKAY. TELL
US CENTER DOLLIES MOVED TO FIVE
TWO ONE FOUR SEVENTEEN ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. IS A FURTHER
DISCUSSION WE CAN CALL FOR THE
ROLE. ADAM NUMBER FOUR AB FOUR
SEVENTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR LEYVA. CHOI BOGUE. JUST
GOING BACK TO THE ROLE OKAY.
SINCE HI BUT TROUBLED- HI
CORTESE DALLI DALLI I GLAZER
AYE GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN. THE.
THANK YOU LEAVE THAT ARE STILL
OPEN. FOR I
- WE HAVE A MOTION
YEAH. WE'LL GO AHEAD AND BRING
BACK AB FOR NINETY EIGHT AN
OPEN THE ROLL CALL FILE NUMBER
FIVE AB FOUR NINETY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING
NINE VICE CHAIR VOTING ONLINE
KERN VOTERS TO ZERO CORTESE.
DELI DELI I GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE PAN. THE
MOTION IS FIVE TWO ZERO AND WE
WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN.
WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND BRING BACK AB ONE ONE
ONE ONE FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN. FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AB ONE ONE ONE. ELEVEN ELEVEN
SHE'S ME MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR HAS NOT VOTED VICE CHAIR
HAS NOT VOTED CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO ZERO CENTER LEYVA. OF
CHIRLA BUG HI THE TROUBLE
OCCURRED TENNESSEE. DALY GLAZER
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE PAN. YEAH
IN WILL LEAVE THAT UP OPEN AS
WELL.
GOOD MORNING WILL START
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CONSENTS CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE
CHAIR VOTING ARE THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO PARTISI. I
COULD HAVE THE AYE MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE PAN. I WILL LEAVE
M. THE CONSENT CALENDAR ON CALL
FOR OUR ABSENT MEMBERS. WE'LL
GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTEEN. FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOR A BEFORE
SEVENTEEN MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR HAS NOT VOTED FOR SURE
VOTING I THE CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE ZERO LEYVA. COURTESY
COURTESY AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE
AYE PAN. SEVEN THE BILL HAS
CURRENTLY FIVE BOATS AND LEAVE
THAT ON CALL. WILL MOVE ON TO
FILE NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY FOUR
NINETY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK SILVA. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE EIGHTY FOUR NINETY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING ON
A VICE CHAIR VOTING NINE
CURRENT VOTE FIVE ZERO
COURTESY. CURTIS III PAM. SIX
ZERO. THE BILL HAS SIX THERE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR OUR
AFTER MEMBERS. WILL MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB SEVEN SIXTY
WE NEED A MOTION FOR THAT BILL.
GIVER A MOTION FROM SENATOR
MCGUIRE. FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
A. B. SEVEN SIXTY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR LEYVA
BUTCHAO WILL VOTE NO PHOTOBOOK
NO COURTESY CATCHES THE EYE
DALLI DALLI NOW GLAZER. POLICE
ARE NOT VOTING REQUIRE. REQUIRE
AYE PAN. THE BILL HAS A TWO TO
VOTE AND LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND WILL MOVE ON
TO- ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB ONE
ONE ONE ONE CRISIS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN. FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB ELEVEN ELEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR HAS NOT
VOTED BY SHARE VOTING I CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO. FOUR CHEVY.
PROTECT THE AYE PAN. THE BILL
HAS FIVE IT IS FIVE TWO ZERO
HOLY THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
HELLO. IT'S BEEN A
VERY BUSY MORNING FOR ALBIA
SENATORS. BUT COMMITTEES WILL
OPEN THE ROLE FOR- THE CONTENT
OF THE CONSENT TO OPEN THEIR
OWN FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CONSENT CHERVONA NINE VICE
CHAIR VOTING ON THE CURRENT
VOTE IS SIX ZERO SENATOR PAN.
HAN HI SEVEN ZERO. AND THAT
BILL PASSES WITH THE SEVEN ZERO
VOTE. WHEN I OPENED THE ROLE
FOR ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY
FOUR SEVENTEEN. ADAM NUMBER FOR
A BEFORE SEVENTEEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE RE
REFER RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. THE CHAIR
HAS NOT VOTED. BY SURE VOTING
ONLINE THE CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
ZERO. SENATOR LEYVA LEYVA AYE
SENATOR PAM HI PAM HI. OKAY IN
THAT BILL MOVES OUT. YEAH-
RIGHT. OKAY OKAY. YEAH FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B. FOUR
NINETY EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING ON MY VOICE HEARD
VOTING NINE CURRENT VOTE IS SIX
ZERO SENATOR PAM ALL RIGHT
HANAE THE BILL'S OUT SEVEN ZERO
WITH OPEN THE ROLE ON FILE ITEM
SIX AB SIX SEVEN SIX SEVEN
SIXTY TWO GROUPS. FILE NUMBER
SIX AB SEVEN SIXTY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR HAS NOT
VOTED VISSCHER VOTING NOW WITH
THE CURRENT VOTE IS TO SENATOR
LEYVA HI LEYVA I. LOSER CLOSER
NOT VOTING CENTER PAM HI CAN I
THAT BILLS OUT FORTY TWO.
THIRTY TWO FILE ITEM SEVEN A.
B. ELEVEN ELEVEN PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE. NUMBER SEVEN AB
ELEVEN ELEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR HAS NOT VOTED VICE CHAIR
VOTING I CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE
ZERO SENATOR LEYVA HI LEYVA HI
PAM HI CAN I GET BILLS OUT
SEVEN ZERO. IF THIS IS A CLEAR
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR I DID NOT
HEAR THE FI I KNOW VOTED BY IN
YOUR FINAL VOTE DECLARATIONS.
FILE ITEM FOR AB FOUR SEVENTEEN
IS OUT SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME. AND MADAM CHAIR
HAVE WE DONE EVERYTHING
EXCELLENT OKAY LET'S. CLOSE IT
DOWN SENATOR I WILL SEE YOU
SHORTLY. YES. THANK YOU MUCH
APPRECIATED ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TDAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE OR
VISIT UR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE
COMMITTEE. ON EDUCATION IS
ADJOURNED.